[Música]
la cámara de representantes de Estados
Unidos suspendió la sesión de votación
para elegir a su nuevo presidente en
tres ocasiones el nominado republicano
Kevin mccarthy ha perdido la elección
debido al boicot de los integrantes más
radicales de su partido
Brasil dio el último adiós a Rey le fue
sepultado en el Memorial necrópolis
ecuménica de santos en una ceremonia
reservada a familiares y amigos próximos
tras numerosos homenajes en los que
miles de personas despidieron al Astro
brasileño que falleció a los 82 años el
29 de diciembre
el Primer Ministro de Israel defendió la
criticada visita de suministro de
seguridad nacional el ultraderechista y
tamar vengavir a la Explanada de las
mezquitas esto luego de que Estados
Unidos reclamara al mandatario Que
respete el estatus quo del sitio sagrado
para judíos y musulmanes
a ustedes gracias por continuar con
nosotros en France 24 soy Valentina
Torres Sánchez y es un gusto
acompañarlos comenzamos en Estados
Unidos porque la cámara de
representantes suspendió la sesión de
votación en la que debía elegir a un
presidente o portavoz de la mayoría que
en esta legislatura pertenece a los
republicanos para que reemplace a la
demócrata Nancy pelosi por tercera vez
el nominado republicano Kevin mccarthy
no obtuvo los votos suficientes para
hacerse con la vocería y deberá esperar
hasta este miércoles para saber si lo
logrará Andrés granadillo tiene los
detalles
el ala dura republicana se resiste a
darle el voto a Kevin mccarthy y por el
momento no logra convertirse en el
presidente de la cámara de
representantes es la primera vez en Cien
años que un nominado a este cargo no
consigue Que los representantes de su
propio partido voten por él la falta de
consenso ha hecho que sus partidarios se
enfrenten para buscar los votos
suficientes
mucho más gente ha tomado el dinero de
Kevin mccarthy para ser elegido y luego
hay unos cuantos que no quieren apoyarle
Como portavoz así que imagínate Esto no
es nada sobre el país se trata de Kevin
Simplemente no les gusta Kevin Mccartney
El desafío es su postulación comenzó
cuando uno de los representantes
republicanos propuso a Andy Beach como
portavoz un congresista de freedom cocus
que está alineado con las políticas de
Donald Trump al menos 19 conservadores
decidieron dejar de apoyar a mccarthy
quien necesita 218 votos en la cámara de
representantes y hasta el momento ha
obtenido 203 en medio del caos los
demócratas nominaron a
primera afroamericano que asumirá la
vocería de La minoría en la cámara
el escrutinio coincide en que el número
total de votos emitidos es de 434
de los cuales el honorable hakim jeffers
del estado de Nueva York ha recibido 212
el honorable Kevin mccarthy del estado
de California ha recibido 203 los
republicanos de la cámara de
representantes están ansiosos por
enfrentarse a la agenda del presidente
Joe biden tras dos años de control del
partido demócrata de ambas cámaras del
congreso pero hasta este miércoles se
sabrá si podrán unificar su voz como
partido de oposición
en una multitudinaria caravana miles de
aficionados despidieron a peleé en la
ciudad de santos más de 200.000 personas
pudieron ver el féretro del exfutbolista
durante 24 horas antes de que fuera
llevado a un cementerio al frente del
estadio Vila belmiro donde fue sepultado
en una última ceremonia privada Andrés
triviño tiene los detalles de La
despedida al considerado rey del fútbol
Brasil despidió al rey mundial del
fútbol
miles de aficionados dieron su última
diosa peleé en un multitudinario y
sentido recorrido realizado por las
calles de Santos la ciudad que lo vio
convertirse en uno de los mejores
jugadores de la historia
de parte de la familia estamos
agradecidos con todos con todos por todo
el amor por todo el cariño por el
respeto
y bueno para expresar nuestra gratitud
el sentimiento más grande de nuestra
familia es la gratitud de un futbolista
es la gratitud Gracias a todos
tras 24 horas de cámara ardiente las
puertas del estadio Vila belmiro donde
jugó Pelé fueron cerradas al público
luego de que 230.000 personas acudieran
a despedirse del exjugador del Santos
incluyendo al recién posesionado
presidente Luis Ignacio Lula da Silva
quien participó en una misa informal en
su honor creo que el mundo le debe mucho
a Pelé sobre todo la dignidad fue un
hombre que nació cobre negro en un país
donde los prejuicios están muy presentes
y a Pelé nunca le importó eso siempre
supo ser Pelé el mejor el mejor y el más
humilde
un grupo de Cadetes de la policía
militar de Sao Paulo cargo el féretro y
partió con destino al cementerio
Memorial necrópolis ecuménica que
gracias a ser un cementerio vertical
tiene vistas al Vila belmiro
no estamos despidiendo solo a nuestro
Rey estamos despidiendo a un genio
se merece todo lo que está pasando hoy
en el Santos es del Santos para el mundo
[Música]
el entierro se produjo de manera privada
para familiares y amigos aunque se
espera que su Nicho sea abierto al
público Próximamente para que sus
seguidores puedan venerar al rey del
balompié brasileño
vamos ahora a Ecuador porque hoy inició
la campaña para las elecciones
municipales del 5 de Febrero que está
marcadas por la celebración de un
referendo constitucional impulsado por
el gobierno los ciudadanos llamados a
las urnas tendrán que decidir sobre
temas como la extradición cambios en la
conformación de la asamblea nacional y
más controles a los casi 280 movimientos
políticos que hay en el país Gustavo
Ortega corresponsal de France 24 en
Quito nos dio más detalles
en Ecuador del año 2023 comienza con un
proselitismo político atípico es que a
partir del 3 de enero se desarrollará la
campaña electoral durante 30 días en el
que coincidirán dos eventos electorales
y un referéndum constitucional siendo
este el que concentrará la mayor
atención de los electores Ecuatorianos
ocho preguntas que estarán en la
papeleta de referéndum 2023 en el que el
gobierno impulsará modificar la
constitución en temas como la
extradición de criminales relacionados
con el crimen organizado y el
narcotráfico y en la elección de
autoridades de control como los temas
más polémicos de la consulta las otras
estarán relacionadas a la reducción del
número de asambleístas la independencia
de funciones la fiscalía la auditoría
constante de partidos políticos y los
métodos de selección de autoridades de
control entre otros además la creación
de sistemas de producción hídrica y
ambiental un referéndum constitucional
con el que el gobierno pretende afrontar
sus principales retos del año 2023 de
seguridad violencia manejo de las
cárceles reformas laborales e inversión
social entre otros en medio de un
contexto de constantes enfrentamientos
políticos entre El Ejecutivo y el
parlamento El Ejecutivo aspira mejorar
su imagen y se jugará su capital
político muy reducido en menos de dos
años de gobierno en Bolivia legisladores
opositores al gobierno denunciaron ante
la Comisión Interamericana de Derechos
Humanos que Luis Fernando Camacho
gobernador de la región de Santa Cruz
que fue detenido el pasado miércoles se
encuentra en grave de estado de salud
según ellos a causa de torturas y tratos
crueles y que necesita tratamiento
médico especializado por su parte El
Ejecutivo Indicó que la salud de Camacho
es estable y que es posible que reciba
su tratamiento en prisión la ha generado
protestas en Santa Cruz por las que al
menos 70 personas han sido detenidas
cambiamos de tema porque la reciente
visita del ministro de seguridad de
Israel y tamar bengavira a la Explanada
de las mezquitas en Jerusalén este
género tensión con las autoridades de
Palestina Quién es la calificaron como
una provocación por tratarse de un lugar
sagrado tanto para judíos como para
musulmanes Estados Unidos pidió al
Primer Ministro Benjamín de tanyahu que
mantenga el statu quo del lugar Andrés
Meza Muñoz tiene los detalles
es el tercer lugar más sagrado para
musulmanes quienes lo conocen como El
noble santuario y el más sagrado para
los judíos quienes lo llaman el monte
del templo este sitio ha estado siempre
en el centro de las disputas entre
israelíes y palestinos y ahora un nuevo
motivo amenaza con avivar las tensiones
la visita del ministro de seguridad
Nacional de Israel el ultraderechista y
tamal vengavir y que autoridades
palestinas califican como una
provocación
es un desafío para los sentimientos del
pueblo palestino y hacemos un llamado a
todo nuestro pueblo que frustró el
complot que tiene como objetivo
convertir el santuario en un templo
judío y esto es una violación a todas
las normas valores acuerdos leyes
internacionales y compromisos de Israel
venga abrirse paseó brevemente por la
periferia del complejo por primera vez
desde que asumió el cargo En el gabinete
de ultraderecha y según un funcionario
israelí el ministro no incumplió el
acuerdo de statu quo heredado del
conflicto de 1967 que permite a los no
musulmanes visitar el lugar con la
condición de
desde hace tiempo bengaví reclama un
mayor acceso para los judíos el monte
del templo está abierto para todos Sí
también para judíos en el gobierno del
que soy miembro no habrá discriminación
racista y los judíos visitarán el monte
del templo en los últimos años se ha
visto un creciente número de
nacionalistas que suben a este lugar a
rezar de manera oculta en el año 2000 la
visita a la Explanada del entonces líder
israelí de la oposición el derechista
Ariel Sharon fue recibida como una
provocación y al día siguiente se
produjeron sangrientos enfrentamientos
que marcaron el inicio de la segunda
intifada finalizamos en el Vaticano
donde se llevó a cabo el segundo día de
Capilla ardiente del Papa Benedicto 16
durante la jornada de unos 70.000 fieles
se acercaron hasta el lugar para rendir
tributo al fallecido pontífice cuya
capilla ardiente finaliza este miércoles
el funeral se llevará a cabo el jueves 5
de enero será presidido por el Papa
Francisco
brinda el informativo volvemos en breve
[Música]